[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes amis
quand j'écoutais l'ardeur de frédéric
comme je voyais la pugnacité de ham
quand j'écoutais la façon recueilli
attentive dont vous prêtiez garde à tous
les propos de manfred et quand je voyais
cette manière qui lui est si propre cas
françois-xavier de retirer la politique
vers le haut
lui qui lors de ce débat télévisé des
européennes là où les autres sortaient
des passes hier des passoires rouge tel
autre un segment de piment d'espelette
un dernier une paire de menottes lui a
sorti un livre un livre et pas n'importe
quel livre le livre de l'iliade d'homère
je me dis que je suis fier de nous
retrouver de nous retrouver faisant de
la vraie politique de nous retrouver
tirant les choses vers le haut je suis
fier de sentir qu ensemble en deux ans
nous avons petit à petit reconstruit la
dynamique de notre famille politique
je suis fier de vous sentir présent avec
de l'envié avec de l'enthousiasmé je
suis fier de nous voir rassemblées avec
tous nos parlementaires
ici autour de cette terre d'alsace avec
les amis de lorraine de france comté de
bourgogne qui sont venus je suis fier de
pouvoir venir devant vous et vous dire
dans cette campagne des européennes il y
à une liste qui a une dynamique
il y à une liste qui a fait bouger les
choses il y à une liste qui est en train
de déjouer tous les pronostics
c'est celle des républicains c'est pour
moi ma plus grande fierté
je voudrais d'abord remercier mon fred
il n'y a pas que les alsaciens en france
qui savent parler allemand
je crois qu'il ya quand même pas
beaucoup d'assistance et publique dans
laquelle on peut faire un discours en
allemand sans qu'il n'y ait même pas 10%
de la salle qui est un casque y arriver
à se faire applaudir manfred ainsi
steiner et insistent à 1h10 in
strassburg civile comme un échec si
manfred terre insiste à une fraude
pyramidale fayard mille tonnes dà nang
que arbeiter manfred cystite sous couvre
feu des infos p manfred et lipides comme
byron explique phil comme on dit in
strassburg faut 12 ou stark arbitre has
to be in fraude pure frankreich tanker
manfred soeur danna rilov
mais mes amis je le dis aussi parce que
la présence de mende fred nous dit
quelque chose dans cette campagne des
européennes
quand on croit à l'europe on croit dans
la relation franco allemande
quand on veut faire avancer l'europe
on sait qu'on ne peut le faire que quand
la france et l'allemagne sont unis quand
on prétend construire l'europe de demain
on n'oublie jamais cette leçon en europe
quand on est isolé on ne pèse rien tous
les présidents de la république l'avait
compris françois mitterrand l'avait
compris
jacques chirac l'avait compris nicolas
sarkozy l'avait compris
même françois hollande l'avait compris
et bien mes amis et bien mes amis et
bien mes amis je veux vous le dire dans
cette période difficile que traverse la
relation franco allemande
nous nous n'oublions pas ce message nous
nous croyons dans la nécessité d'une
confiance mutuelle entre la france et
l'allemagne et je suis heureux
qu'aujourd'hui notre famille politique
soit celle en france qui incarne cette
relation entre la france et l'allemagne
merci à vous
anne je t'avais fait cette promesse et
je t'avais fait cette promesse que tu
serais devant dans notre liste et qu'à
travers toi ce serait aussi la
reconnaissance de ceux qui ont travaillé
et qui ont bien mené leur travail à
l'intérieur de notre groupe du ppe
oui françois xavier l'a très bien dit tu
à l'image de ce que je veux plus des
députés engagé qui connaissent leurs
dossiers qui les travaillent qui sont
capables de faire avancer parfois des
petites choses en apparence mais qui
compte tellement qui sait par exemple
que c'est toi qui a oeuvré pour que
quand on franchit la frontière allemande
et que son téléphone mobile est avec
nous on ne se voit pas appliquée dès
surtarification petit dossier en
apparence mais qui pourtant contes pour
tous ceux qui franchissent lorrain
chaque jour et qui vont travailler un
hôtel de mon c'est toi qui a travaillé
sur ces dossiers anne l'a fait à l'image
de bien d'autres dossiers que nous avons
fait avancer comme la lutte contre le
terrorisme comme le fait de travailler
pour une meilleure intégration de nos
universités comme le fait de travailler
pour mieux surveiller les
investissements étrangers qui viennent
chez nous tout cela était porté par un
groupe
le groupe du ppe vous êtes tous dans
cette salle les héritiers de ce groupe
seconde qui vient dans notre famille
politique en france à la fois des
racines du gaullisme et de la démocratie
chrétienne
ce groupe qui a fondé l'union européenne
et dont vous êtes tous les héritiers
seconde qui même dans les périodes les
plus difficiles et la famille politique
qui a toujours veillé à ce que la voix
est le message de l'europe ne soit pas
perdue la fierté que les républicains et
le centre peuvent apporter c'est que
quand on vote pour nous on permet à la
france de saint céré et de porter sa
voix à l'égard de la plus grande famille
politique européenne la plus grande
famille politique européenne
j'aime mon pays je ne veux pas que la
france joue en seconde division
et bien je vous le dirai petelo tour de
vous une voie pour en marche c'est une
voix perdues pour l' influence de la
france en europe parce que le président
de la république dans sa folie à décider
qui l'isolerait la france qu'il créerait
un petit groupe de son côté que ce
serait sans doute un des plus petits
groupes du parlement européen et que
cela c'est une influence perdue pour la
france avec les républicains et avec les
centristes vous êtes au coeur du parti
populaire européen et nous défendons nos
intérêts ici à strasbourg
j'ai vécu ici à strasbourg avec ma femme
et nous n'en gardons que des souvenirs
heureux
françois-xavier tu admirablement
rappeler et venir viendrait pas ce
qu'est l'extraordinaire apport de
l'alsace et de cette culture rhennam à
l'humanisme européen est ici à
strasbourg
je veux moi aussi dire les choses
clairement le fait que le parlement soit
à strasbourg
c'est aussi un signe et c'est le signe
que l'europe ne peut pas être que
l'europe administrative de bruxelles
pourquoi est ce qu'il faut le parlement
à strasbourg
parce que cela nous rappelle que
l'europe c'est autre chose qu'une
construction administrative
ils veulent un siège unique pour le
parlement eh bien je leur dis d'accord
ce siège unique
il est à strasbourg s'est inscrit dans
les traités de l'union européenne
pourquoi pensez vous que les choses
bougent pour nous pourquoi pensez-vous
que en l'espace de deux mois
nous avons gagné sept points ce n'est
pas juste une petite question
d'arithmétique politicienne pourquoi les
choses bougent parce que les français
veulent le choix pourquoi les choses
bougent parce que les français refusent
d'être condamné à la réédition du second
tour de la présidentielle
pourquoi les choses bougent parce que
les français ne veulent pas être
condamné avoir à choisir entre le chaos
de marine le pen d'un côté et la
déception des manuels macron pourquoi
sommes nous là parce que la
responsabilité des républicains céderait
offrir le choix car les deux sont des
impasses marine le pen c'est la
déconstruction de l'europe
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de la manche pour
comprendre le chaos que cela serait
marine le pen c'est la sortie de l'euro
dans un pays comme le nôtre grévé par
les déficits et les dettes cela
signifiera la dévaluation de notre
monnaie l'appauvrissement du patrimoine
de tous ceux qui sont dans cette salle
la perte de salaire
la perte de pouvoir d'achat marine le
pen porte un projet de déconstruction de
l'europe
c'est pour cette raison que je
combattrai jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
les idées de marine le pen sur le plan
européen
je n'en veux pas les républicains sont
pour l'europe
alors oui refonder l'europe pour établir
la france mais refonder l'europe parce
que c'est la deuxième 1 passe emmanuel
macron n'a pas compris qu'il fallait
changer l'europe l'europe qu'il nous
propose c'est toujours plus de l'europe
qui a échoué plus d'élargissement comme
s'il n'y avait pas déjà suffisamment
pays différents avec lesquels nous avons
tellement de mal à nous entendre
c'est l'europe des normes lui qui
propose dans chacun de ses discours de
créer des normes et des agences
supplémentaires
c'est l'europe des impôts lui qui en un
discours a proposé de créer quatre taxes
supplémentaires européenne c'est
l'europe de la bureaucratie
c'est l'europe au contraire que nous ne
nous voulons pas il n'a pas compris que
si l'on voulait redonner un souffle à
l'europe comme on ferait d'eux l'a très
bien dit il fallait avoir la volonté de
changer l'europe
alors oui marine le pen emmanuel macron
sont les deux visages d'une même impasse
une impasse qui nous condamne à ne pas
repenser l'europe et à lui redonner un
souffle
nous croyons dans la nécessité du projet
européen et nous sommes convaincus que
pour cela il faut remettre l'europe sur
le bon chemin
quand on nous demande qu elle l europe
que vous voulez et bien répondait
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
que nous aimions l'europe que nous
voulons c'est l'europe qui marchait
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
qui a du souffle l'europe que nous
voulons c'est l'europe qui avait des
projets l'europe que nous voulons c'est
l'europe qui est capable de défier tout
à la fois la chine et les états unis
l'europe que nous voulons c'est celle
qui est capable de répondre à la fois ou
à la dérégulation climatique et en même
temps à l'immigration l'europe que nous
voulons c'est une europe qui protège et
qui en même temps assure l'avenir de nos
enfants
l'europe que nous voulons c'est celle
qui s'appuie tout à la fois sur nos
racines et a le goût de l'avenir et du
souffle de demain c'est celle là
l'europe que nous voulons
et cette europe c'est celle que porte et
défend françois xavier
c'est celle que ce trio nous a permis de
reprendre c'est celle que la liste avec
la diversité tous ces visages nous
apporte avec cette union pour laquelle
je me suis battu et que j'ai sous les
yeux entre la droite et le centre
on me disait où l'alarmé on n'arrivera
pas à se rassembler et si on veut faire
l'union de la droite et du centre il
faudrait que la droite ne disent plus
rien je n'ai jamais cru à cette
politique dans laquelle on s'excuse de
ses valeurs et de ses idées je pense que
c'est la politique et coeur j'ai
toujours été convaincu que pour
reconstruire la droite il fallait
assumer au grand jour nos idées etc
assumer au grand jour ses idées
pouvaient se faire tout en rassemblant
tous ceux qui ont envie devraient
ensemble notre liste et la liste du
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
hervé morin est à nos côtés
la graine que nous avons planté est une
graine sur laquelle nous construirons
les victoires de demain
merci aux centristes d'avoir rejoint les
républicains et de porter ensemble ce
défi
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes les seuls à parler
d'europe
les autres parlent de bruxelles certains
parlent de la commission européenne
d'autres s'enfoncent dans un
affrontement entre le souverainisme où
le fédéralisme mais qui parle de
l'europe qui parlent de cette europe
comme le fait françois xavier qui parle
de la civilisation
parce que ne vous y trompez pas un conte
sur les ruines de la guerre
les pères fondateurs ont décidé de
mettre sur le drapeau européen
les couronnes les étoiles de la couronne
de la vierge il avait conscience qu'il
faisait précisément un projet de
civilisation
il avait conscience que ce qu'il faisait
ça n'était pas qu'une construction
administrative
c'était tout autre chose la question que
nous nous posons tous aujourd'hui elle
n'a pas changé par rapport à celle des
pères fondateurs
la question qu'il se pose est que nous
nous posons nous sommes les héritiers
d'une merveilleuse civilisation et la
question qui nous en tous sommes nous
condamnés à renoncer à notre mode de vie
où allons-nous pouvoir à notre tour
transmettre à nos enfants ce que nous
sommes ce que nous aimons ce que nous
avons chéri pour qu'à leur tour ils
puissent en être les héritiers et qu'il
puisse faire vivre dans l'avenir ce
qu'ils ont reçu être à la fois fier de
ce qu'on a reçues et en être digne la
question que nous nous posons tous est
la suivante est ce que la civilisation
européenne est morte ou est ce que nous
sommes capables de lui donner une
renaissance et un nouveau souffle
c'est cela la question que nous nous
posons dans cette élection européenne
et bien je le crois du fond de mon coeur
la civilisation européenne n'est pas
morte
oui les défis sont massifs oui les
concurrents sont autour de nous oui il
ya la pression de l'islamisme et du
multiculturalisme
oui il y a le risque du décrochage de
notre économie messi enfin nous ouvrons
les yeux non la civilisation européenne
n'est pas morte elle peut être refondée
et elle peut rétablir avec elle tout à
la fois
france et l'europe
une civilisation manfred une
civilisation d'abord ce sont des
frontières il y a des limites
tout le monde n'appartient pas à
l'europe et manfred tu auras notre
soutien total dont le fait de mettre fin
une bonne fois pour toutes à ce cinéma
des négociations avec la turquie la
turquie n'est pas européenne elle ne le
sera jamais
et de la même manière mais ami emmanuel
macron n'a pas tiré les leçons des
échecs de l'élargissement nous avons
fait rentrer trop de pays trop vite cela
ne peut pas fonctionner à bucarest il
est allé dire en roumanie qu'il fallait
que la roumanie et la bulgarie rentrer
au plus vite dans l'espace schengen à
trieste
il a dit qu'il fallait que les balkans
rentrer au plus tôt dans l'union
européenne
il s'apprête en juin à ouvrir les
négociations avec l'albanie et bien
françois-xavier and tous ceux qui sont
ici le savent eux signent en étant sur
notre liste
un engagement clair ils voteront au
cours du mandat qui vient contre toute
décision qui ouvrira la porte à de
futurs élargissements
il faut renforcer l'europe et arrêter de
la perte dans des élargissements
excessif
[Applaudissements]
des frontières et défendre ses
frontières comme j'étais heureux manfred
d'entendre que tu en faisais ma première
priorité
le défendons nous le principe d'une
double protection de nos frontières il
faut d'abord une protection européenne
ce que n'a pas compris marine le pen si
l'europe ne protège pas nos frontières
en espagne en italie en grèce
alors ceux qui rentrent par là viendront
tôt ou tard chez nous nous avons besoin
d'un corps de gardes côtes
nous avons besoin que ceux qui viennent
en direction de l'europe soit reconduit
sur les côtes africaines
nous avons besoin que les demandes
d'asile ne soit pas faite sur le
continent européen mais sur le continent
africain et nous avons besoin que la
règle soit clair si l'on est rentré
illégalement en europe on ne se verra
plus jamais reconnu un droit au titre de
séjour parce que sinon c'est une prime à
l'illégalité et à ceux qui ne respectent
pas nos règles de loi il est temps de
remettre de l'ordre
et une protection européenne et la
deuxième que nous demandons c'est une
protection nationale
je veux bien que vous me comprenez nous
ne demandons pas la restauration des
contrôles quand on passe le rhin nous ne
demandons pas que les frontaliers qui
vont travailler en direction de
l'allemagne de la suisse du luxembourg
de l'italie de l'espagne se voient
contraints dans leur vie quotidienne
la seule chose que je demande c'est
qu'on ait la possibilité en alsace de
contrôler les migrants illégaux qui
rentrent en alsace la seule chose que je
demande c'est qu'on ait la possibilité
de contrôler les migrants illégaux qui
francis les alpes la seule chose que je
demande c'est que la france garde la
maîtrise de sa politique d'immigration
et que si l'allemagne fait un choix pour
sa politique d'immigration ce choix là
ne s'impose pas à la france parce que
nous n'avons pas la même démographie et
que nous n'avons pas le même niveau de
chômage une double protection de nos
frontières
une protection européenne et une
protection nationale pour retrouver la
maîtrise de notre émigration et ce sujet
est important parce qu'il est si
symbolique
nous nous croyons à l'europe et c'est
notre différence par rapport à marine le
pen et nous croyons qu'on peut tout à la
fois construire l'europe et d'appuyer
sur la puissance de nos nations
l'erreur majeure qui a été commise
c'est d'un côté marine le pen pas
d'europe de l'autre côté emmanuel macron
pas de nation moi je crois qu'il faut
les deux il faut à la fois la force des
nations et il faut la force de l'europe
c'est cela l'europe des pères fondateurs
et c'est cela l'europe à laquelle nous
croyons
[Applaudissements]
mais pour qu'il y est une civilisation
il faut des projets en commun
françois-xavier l'a si bien dit or
toutes ces normes qui énerve qui est
bête qui abrutissent toutes ces normes
qui finissent par tourner le dos bon
sens nous étions tout à l'heure
bilwisheim sur une exploitation de
producteurs d'aspergés
pensez vous qu'il ya des normes qui lui
interdisent d'avoir des lits superposés
pour pouvoir loger les saisonniers qui
viennent récolter les asperges
mais où est on allé se loger
pensez vous que quand l'inspection du
travail vient c'est lui elle mesure la
taille de ces toilettes et les
différentes normes qui sont applicables
au lieu de s'assurer qu'ils puissent
continuer à avoir du travail
mais où sommes nous tombés ce n'est pas
cela dont on a besoin et la france est
souvent bien plus folle que l'allemagne
parce que nous on est tellement plus
intelligent compan tellement plus de
normes et qu'au lieu d'avoir ce minimum
de pragmatisme qui ferait tellement du
bien
nous nous sentons toujours obligé de
faire un tout petit peu plus dans ces
normes folle qui décourage tout ceux qui
veulent entreprendre stop les normes
stop
mais par contre des projets manfred
comme tu as raison et comme nous de
supporter en la matière que la
commission européenne puisse elle même
porté la maîtrise d'ouvragé de
l'entretien du rang pour le désensabler
assuré que la circulation puisse
continuer à se faire sur l'aura que la
commission européenne puisse se voir
confier la possibilité de piloter elle
même des projets pour la couverture
intégrale en internet très haut débit et
en 5 g de l'ensemble du continent
européen que la commission européenne
puisse adopter une grande cause
européenne pendant la durée de son
mandat et qui permettrait de mettre en
commun tous les travaux de recherche sur
le cancer ou sur alzheimer pour que
demain puissent se dire je suis fier
d'appartenir au continent qui a permis
de trouver le remède aux maladies
neurodégénératives et aux maladies
d'alzheimer qui sont sans doute une des
plus grandes menaces qui nous attend
demain cela c'est l'europe des projets
ça c'est l'europe qui permet de remettre
un coeur dans la civilisation
et une civilisation enfin c'est la
défense d'une culture
oui cette culture est aujourd'hui menacé
oui il ya aujourd'hui des gens qui
détestent tout ce que nous sommes
oui il ya aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
parfois nés dans notre pays sur le
continent européen qui ont bénéficié de
tout ce que nous leur avons offert et
qui ont tourné leur haine et leur arme
contre ce qu'ils auront tout donné
que s'est il passé comment avons nous pu
faire peur de temps d' aveuglement
vous le savez parfois je suis en colère
quand au lendemain des attentats à
l'image de la souffrance terrible que
vous avez connu ici à strasbourg
à l'image de celle que moi j'ai connu
dans ma région qui a aussi été
endeuillée par des attentats à l'image
des êtres chers qui me sont très proches
et qui ont perdu des gens de leur
famille dans l'attentât du bataclan et à
chaque fois nous faisons preuve de la
même naïveté
il ya le temps de la compassion
indispensable mais derrière il n'ya rien
ne prenons jamais les mesures qui
s'imposent on sort les petites bougies
et on continue comme avant
on fait de grands discours contre
l'islamisme politique et on continue
comme avant et on n'ouvre pas les yeux
et on ne réalise pas ce que nous avons à
combattre est ce qui serait pourtant
indispensable de faire nous avons à
combattre l'intégrisme islamiste
il faut le combattre de toutes nos
forces parce que sinon il continuera à y
avoir des morts
et cela mes amis ce sont des mesures
très concrètes
il faut fermer les mosquées salafistes
en europe
en europe il faut interdire aux imams
qui prêchent la haine de pouvoir
continuer chaque vendredi à faire leurs
prêches en incitant au meurtre et à la
haine de l'autre
il faut refuser que des puissances
étrangères puissent venir financer des
mosquées dont ensuite elles se servent
pour faire prospérer à l'ombre des
minarets les réseaux de m le président
de la république a parlé hier de l'islam
politique
mais moi ce que j'attends ça n'est pas
qu'il en parle c'est qu'il est fils
comment comprendre que notre pays est
accepté que le président de la
république est accepté que le
gouvernement est accepté de faire
revenir sur le sol français 200
djihadistes qui étaient partis en syrie
non mes amis notre parole est clair les
jihadistes partis en syrie ne doivent
pas revenir en europe et nous exigeons
qu'il soit jugé
là-bas et qu'il soit gardé là bas ils
ont trahi l'europe
ils ne doivent pas revenir sur le
continent européen
et quand je vois que marine le pen a
voté contre cette mesure que vous avez
porté qui consistait à s'assurer que des
terroristes ne puissent pas monter dans
des avions et que des logiciels puissent
permettre de les surveiller et qu'elle a
donné comme explication à son vote
les terroristes ne prennent pas l'avion
mesure-t-on l'ampleur de ce qu'est la
crédibilité de telles personnes
après les attentats du 11 septembre dans
un pays comme le nôtre où ces deux
barbares qu'était mohamed merah et
monsieur kwasi avaient tous les deux
bien évidemment pris l'avion pour se
rendre au yémen et pour se rendre en
afghanistan
madame le pen vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur dans cette lutte contre le sujet
qui est indispensable et qui est celui
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
et mes amis enfin défendre notre
civilisation s'est retrouvé le droit
d'assumer ce que nous sommes
que s'est il passé notre pays a
accueilli pendant des années des gens
qui venaient de partout qui venait de
pologne qui venait de belgique qui
venaient d'italie qui venait d'espagne
qui venait du portugal qui venaient du
sud de la méditerranée et qui se sont
admirablement intégré qui se sont
intégrés par ce qu'ils venaient en ayant
la volonté de travailler et parce qu'il
venait en ayant la volonté de faire leur
ce qu'était notre civilisation est petit
à petit angela merkel l'a très bien
dénoncer quand elle a dit nous sommes
tombées dans l'impasse du
multiculturalisme est bien petit à petit
nous avons inversé le devoir
d'intégration
nous avons laissé croire que ça n'était
pas à celui qui venait de s'intégrer
mais que c'était à nous de nous adapter
aux modes de vie de celui qui venait
nous avons renoncé petit à petit à
porter la transmission de notre culture
la fierté de notre histoire à enseigner
notre littérature à défendre notre mode
de vie
tu l'as dit françois xavier il y à une
leçon à notre dame la leçon de notre
dame c'est qu'une civilisation c'est
précieux
la leçon de notre dame c'est qu'il ya
des incendies visible mais la leçon de
notre dame c'est aussi qu'il ya des
incendies invisible
la leçon de notre dame c'est que quand
on est aveugle ou lâche on peut perdre
ce qu'on nous a transmis à chaque fois
que nous acceptons que dans une salle de
classe on n'enseigne plus les racines
chrétiennes de notre pays à chaque fois
que nous acceptons que dans une salle de
classe
on n'enseigne plus la shoah parce que
cela aboutit à une insurrection à chaque
fois que nous assumons que dans un
quartier une femme se voit forcée de
porter le voile parce qu'on ne laisse
pas le choix et madame l'oiseau comment
comprendre vous qui est la tête de liste
dans marche que vous ayez pu dire que
vous ne voyez pas la différence entre le
foulard islamique et le foulard que
portait serait manuel moi la différence
je la vois bien elle est dans la
conception de la liberté de la femme
madame loiseau
à chaque fois que dans un hôpital on
refuse qu'une femme soit soigné par un
médecin homme parce que ce ne serait pas
compatible
à chaque fois que nous renonçons
enseigner un bout de ce que nous sommes
à chaque fois que nous capitulons en
acceptant qu'on ne puisse plus même
mettre nos crèches au moment de noël
ces objets qui sont si symbolique pour
ce qu'est notre identité et notre
culture
à chaque fois que nous faisons cela nous
acceptons de renoncer un petit bout de
nous mêmes
eh bien je crois qu'il faut exactement
l'inversé
il faut avoir la générosité au contraire
de transmettre à celui qui vient chez
nous ce que nous sommes
il faut avoir la générosité de
transmettre à nos enfants ce que
nous-mêmes nous avons appris il faut
avoir la générosité de leur apprendre
qu'ils ont la chance d'avoir grandi dans
un continent européen qui a vu à la fois
poussé molière et goethe et qu'ils
doivent en être fier il faut avoir juste
cette générosité d'enseigner à ceux qui
viennent que la meilleure garantie pour
construire l'avenir c'est d'avoir des
racines c'est d'avoir des fondations
essaie de comprendre que la meilleure
protection de l'avenir c'est de savoir
d'où l'on vient
quand on veut avancer il faut savoir
c'est cela ce que nous nous portons dans
cette élection européenne
alors oui mes amis je veux que nous
retrouvions le vrai goût de l'europe
l'europe ne peut pas être le nom d'un
vide
l'europe c'est un combat pour défendre
ce que nous avons en commun
l'europe s'est retrouvé cette fierté de
notre identité
l'europe c'est avoir cette envie chaque
jour de défendre ce message si singulier
de l'europe qui n'est propre à aucun
autre
l'europe c'est tout simplement cette
croyance dans le fait de penser que tout
le monde peut devenir européen
mais à une condition qu'il fasse sienne
sa civilisation
c'est cette condition très simple que
nous devons rappeler c'est celui qui
vient sur le continent européen qui doit
s'adapter à l'europe
et ça n'est pas à l'europe de s'adapter
à celui qui vient de l'étranger
les amis il y as j'en suis convaincu en
ce moment quelque chose qui est en train
de bouger
il y a une dynamique qui est en train de
s'installer à l'intérieur de cette
élection il y a tout d'un coup un espoir
que personne n'attendait qui est en
train de se lever
il y à des pronostics qui ont un train
de déjouer
il y a tout d'un coup une petite brève
qui est en train de s'ouvrir et qui
chaque jour qui passe est en train de
s'élargir
il y à des électeurs et des français qui
comme vous et nous ont envie eux aussi
de pouvoir changer les choses
ce moment c'est le nôtre ce moment c'est
celui que nous devons saisir
j'ai besoin de vous il reste 30 jours
il reste trente jours pour amplifier la
dynamique
il reste trente jours pour déjouer tous
les pronostics
il reste trente jours pour leur montrer
que nous sommes bien là et que nous ne
reculerons pas il reste trente jours
pour leur montrer que les républicains
sont de retour il reste trente jours
pour poser les bases tout à la fois
d'une refondation de l'europe et d'un
rétablissement de la france il reste
trente jours dans lesquelles j'ai besoin
de vous soyez là le défi qui nous attend
c'est le plus beau défi c'est celui de
la transmission c'est celui de notre
civilisation
c'est celui de notre histoire c'est
celui de notre passé notre avenir tout à
la fois j'ai besoin de vous refondre
l'ensemble europe
rétablissons la france vive la france et
vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]